nature is here at cop26 to find answers
to the climate science questions you've
been asking
many of you have asked quite simply
is it too late
we pitched this question to scientists
across the conference and they seem to
fall into two camps first the cautiously
optimistic
of course not um i wouldn't be here if
it's too late i think that there has
been uh so much highly relevant research
on the the social impacts of
nature-based solutions which are
actually really critical if we are going
to tackle climate change we're not quite
too late
but we haven't got much time left
and we've really got to do things now
but the basic carbon capture storage
we can do we've got them now they can
build them now we should be building
them now no
the short answer is no we still have a
chance to keep temperatures below
certainly 2 degrees and even 1.5 degrees
one of my colleagues kevin anderson at
the university of manchester he said
there's 95 chance of going to hell in a
hand cart and five percent chance of
making that 1.5 degree target but that
1.5 degree target if we were able to
make that what that means for
livelihoods for quality of life for
health globally is profound and is
something that we should strive for um
to the last possible moment
and the less optimistic
there were those who thought it was
already too late
that's very clear it has come too late
we know that
the ipcc has just issued a report saying
that climate change is happening we were
supposed to prevent it from happening 30
years ago we didn't
so it's definitely too late what we can
do now
is prevent even worse impacts in the
longer term but we cannot prevent worse
impacts in the short term
yes it's becoming too late
because looking at the ipcc assessment
report africa is warming fastest
than any other part of the globe but
unfortunately
the developed nations who cause this
warming are moving so slowly
to give us a sense of why scientists are
so split on this question we tracked
down a researcher who's been studying
and attending climate negotiations since
the very first cop i'm nicholas cerna i
work at new climate institute and the
wageningen university i work on climate
policy and it's basically the interface
between science and policy making we
provide a lot of research and insights
on what
it all means that countries and other
actors are doing on climate whether it's
enough or not whether with all the
actions that are out there we will keep
temperature rise at low levels or not so
it is late it is very late but i don't
think it's too late because we may be
surprised by things that happen faster
than we can imagine and when we've been
posing this is it too late question to
scientists around the conference they
seem to have fallen into two camps there
are those that are cautiously optimistic
and those that feel that is already too
late and we need to now deal with the
consequences
why do you think this divide may have
occurred i think it's not a
straightforward answer to to say whether
it's too late or not it's never too late
you can do certain things maybe there's
a certain technological change that's
coming or
you clean up the mess afterwards by
taking co2 out of the atmosphere again
that's why it's
there's not a clear scientific answer
whether it's too late or not and you're
also part of the climate action tracker
which tracks government's commitments to
climate change how well they're making
due on their promises
how well are nations doing to meet their
climate commitments
our nations are not doing well the
imagination is right but the countries
are not setting the right short-term
targets are not implementing the right
short-term measures and there we still
have a huge gap
if countries do everything that they
have proposed here we would still emit
twice as much greenhouse gas emissions
in 2030 than we should if we wanted to
be on a trajectory towards 1.5 degrees
and the climate action tracker has put
out a new press release and a new
analysis
on tuesday just gone what has this shown
about how things are progressing
the intention of the conference is
to show that countries are on the same
path they want to do things and that's
why in the first week there were many
announcements many countries said we do
this we do that but after that first
week we went back and did a sobering
assessment whether all of this is new
whether it's really driving emissions
down
and we find that yes it is good that we
have it but unfortunately we have not
solved the problem yet if you assume
that all countries implement their
long-term
pledges their net zero targets we would
calculate that the temperature increase
by the end of the century would be 1.8
degrees roundabout however this is only
because of the long-term targets which
we think are not yet really credible
because countries are not implementing
short-term policies
if you take into account only
the short-term targets that countries
have made until 2030
then we calculate a temperature increase
of 2.4 degrees by the end of the century
and if you take the actions that
countries have really been doing not
what they're promising what they really
have been doing then we calculate
temperature increase of 2.7 degrees by
the end of the century and that
definitely would be catastrophic climate
change so you've been at these
negotiations at various kind of
negotiations for a long time do you
think cop 26 has moved the needle at all
corp 26 has moved the needle we
calculate that it has decreased the gap
by roughly 20 20 to 25
and that means to me we have to speed up
doing these kind of conferences every
five years is not enough you have to
have that kind of a pressure moment each
year
that countries come forward with more
until that gap is really close